there's also a lot of people here that
are like naturally transgender they
don't have to have the surgery which is
nice
there's a lot of naturally gender
non-specific kind of orbs of flesh
wandering around
it's true they're so beaten down the
gender down
what's a gender at that point you know
who cares
just a leathery-faced old catrice mitt
crawling down the street
looking for a pool of beer to dunk their
head in what's the [ __ ]
gender at that point you just opened two
legs and all you see is mashed potatoes
anyway
[Applause]
if you sell stuff online you're
definitely
you're definitely in the right business
more people are shopping online than
ever
that means a lot of orders coming in and
a lot of orders you'll need to ship out
fast
that's why online sellers like you need
ship station
amazon fc or even your own website chip
station funnels all the orders into one
simple interface
you can manage from anywhere even your
cell phone with ship station small
business
can now access the same rates reserve
for fortune 500 it's a great product
uh use my code tim dillon to get a
60-day freight trial free trial that's
two months free no hassle
stress free shipping 60-day free trial
two months free no hassle
stress free shipping promo code tim
dillon you can sell your undergarments
you can sell things you stole you can
sell
garbage art that your kids make you
could just say they're dying
what a great idea say your children are
dying
and sell their art my mother said to me
once i'll never respect her more than
the moment she said this
i was like in fifth grade i go mom i
don't have the report done she goes
just tell the teacher i died
i'm like yeah but grandma like works at
the school my mom's like right i guess
don't do that
shipstation.com promo code tim dillon
make ship happen
and then last one here the last one
they're gonna reject a lot of these and
we're gonna have to cut them up when you
if you hear them on the show they'll be
literally yeah
in seconds they'll take out everything
it'll just be like ship station
good literally they will not
we have to send the ads in for approval
now yeah
yeah that's most of what my job is now
is
fighting with them to leave jokes in and
editing
what is their problem they why did the
spoon turn
[Laughter]
[Music]
spoon was with us for a while and then i
went tell them
tell everyone exactly what spoon so
magic spoon told me they said
uh that we can't do any content about uh
children getting abused or
uh uh killed or killed that was their
words
in the act we can't talk about children
being killed or murdered
in the ad for cereal or sexually
assaulted well then i can't do it i
i i try i edit i mean i'll try
i'll try to get through it but i mean no
promises the whole point
of magic spoon is that the kids that
grew up with those cereals growing up
were the types of kids whose parents
went to a bar all night then came home
walked him out of a dead seat just
started pounding on him for no reason
and then passed out the reward for those
kids
was a [ __ ] nice lucky charms
breakfast
they didn't get college out of it they
got a nice breakfast and every now and
then i get to go over their house they'd
have a black eye
true story and a bloody lip and we'd
have a great [ __ ]
cereal breakfast and that's what i was
trying to capture
and then some blue hair [ __ ] tech
[ __ ] they
they got really mad about the the part i
had to edit out was
about the kid getting tied to the
radiator and getting his head beaten
in and then them running him over with
the car over and over
that was brilliant i felt hungry hearing
that
[Laughter]
i wanted a nice crunchy keto cereal
when hearing about that kid being beaten
and then ran over with a car
they didn't like that and what do you
who do you talk to over there people
have to call you
yeah they they they contact me through
our ad guy and then i have to barter
with him and then why not
why don't they contact me
i can include you on the calls oh no bad
idea
bad idea i'll give them a [ __ ] piece
of my mind
i'm not allowed to speak to anyone this
is after the whole airbnb fiasco
i am to be kept silent in a room
with cigarettes and i'm to be let out an
hour a week
and then back into the cage i cannot
speak to the world uh you know but they
never sued us those ladies
oh mila and uh yeah no no no do with
their names now so not test that
sorry but they never sued us no never
never
but uh they were happy about rogan's
comment they were like joe rogan is
welcome any time at this point
is that what they said yeah that's what
they said on their instagram stories was
that what they said
yeah oh good uh joe rogan doesn't need
to go to your house you dirty dyke
because he has real [ __ ] money you
stupid piece of [ __ ]
nobody needs to stay in your litter box
of a [ __ ] house you [ __ ]
wait honeys wait and watch we're just
getting started okay
we're just getting [ __ ] started
you [ __ ] clam divers
they [ __ ] went at me on the gram like
that and you didn't [ __ ] tell me
stories i thought you saw it i didn't
[ __ ]
i'm blocked no
every screenshot ever since i threatened
to kill them i'm blocked
i threatened to kill them they blocked
me like children
so wait a minute what what did they do
they shared that thing
uh that rogan said when you did the
podcast last about how rogan said it was
a beautiful place and he'd love to stay
at a place like he's on
dmt and they said joe rogan is welcome
any time at our airbnb
thank you so much joe
whatever i don't like this alliance
between joe rogan and these two dykes
i don't like it i can see it shaping up
and i don't like it
do you think i did anything wrong no
[Laughter]
dan dan sees a lot of my behavior and
much of it you probably disagree with
uh i mean who can agree with everything
that someone does
you know but you're a young person what
you need to understand
is when you're an older person you
realize the value of going to war with
every person that you saved
we got in trouble for cutting the line
at a whataburger we did that was
[ __ ] though
we didn't even we didn't even know the
line worked we didn't even know the line
was functioning
yeah and it's supposed to be texas tough
guy i'm texas i'm a tough guy i'm going
to shoot you
and then you go on a facebook group like
a con and whine about it
yeah neighbors uncensored yeah neighbors
uncensored
25. you know what that group's about
hard r
you know what that neighbor's uncensored
in texas is about
letting it fly neighbors uncensored how
much coded racial language is in that
group
i just want to post on neighbors
uncensored about the new neighbors they
seem a little different does anyone
share my concerns about the new
neighbors they have a
lot of children i don't know athletic
sure
but i'm a little nervous
i'm a little nervous about them darting
out into the middle of the street to get
a basketball
if you hear what i'm saying it's
neighbors uncensored in texas
expressvpn if you you know what's not
fair
the fact that netflix hides thousands of
shows and movies
from you based on your location and they
have the ner
and then they have the nerve to increase
the price that's right
they've just raised their prices once
again now you could just cancel your
subscription to protest
or you could be smart about it and make
sure you're getting your full money's
worth by using expressvpn like i do
you might not know what's on netflix in
your country is completely different
from someone in the uk or japan has on
theirs
expressvpn i can control which country i
want netflix to think i'm in
this is such an interesting ad because
the hope
the real hope with this service
is that you are watching japanese
netflix
i pray i'm not saying it
i'm saying i pray to god
that you are using this service yes to
watch japanese
netflix
[Laughter]
here's the best part it's not just for
netflix
you can use expressvpn to unlock
shows on other
streaming services too
it's super fast works on your
phone
laptop smart tvs
so you can watch your shows on the big
screen
with zero buffering what
ring of hell is reserved for me after
reading this ad
call to action so be smart
stop paying for i gotta cut that out i
gotta cut that out
it's a joke you can't make it out it's
out edit it out sorry
it's all right it's our last week on
youtube like every week
hope he gets us that [ __ ] look who would
you get your broken spotify buddy
so last every time every episode we go
this will be it so
hopefully patreon is still holding out
for now yeah all of their shows are
white patreon's wild
they've got chapo and kumtown and us and
like anime
people just want to [ __ ] cartoons yeah
anime asmr is big on there
what the [ __ ] is that anime like a
cartoon yeah it's anime but the anime
characters are doing asmr so people can
you like asmr daniel no why not
i don't know i mean i don't have nothing
against it i just don't ever feel like
weird when someone goes
[Laughter]
i told you this the other day what if it
was a really hot girl with my exact
voice
like hottest girls you've seen big tits
everything perfect but it's just my
exact voice
practice i turn off the lights she's
like it's dark yeah
it's real dark this country is wrong
let's practice right now you're on a
date can you do it all right all right
so
hey it's nice to meet you yeah
you're from florida yeah i am where
where are you from
new york but i'm hot like i'm
really hot huge dance i'm just fingering
my perfectly bald pink [ __ ]
but i'm going
so just get expressvpn it helps the show
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
tim dillon that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p on
vpn dot com slash tim dillon to learn
more
see what happened to those hands we'll
we'll shave them down
maybe we'll just put them out but i will
bleep out the that part
well don't we have to get we have to get
approval so we have we're not in a
contract to get approval but we
our word is our bond right
what a horrible bond